the spirit of Linda is the openness of
the discussion and the passion for
science that inspires and connects
beyond the day for 60 years very unusual
scientific meetings have been held in a
small town on Lake Constance in Germany
these days large numbers of Nobel Prize
winners come to the meetings in lindau
the universe starts with with period
recall inflation they come to speculate
to theorize to argue and above all to
meet the future generation
the spirit of Linda is the combination
of scientific excellence deep passion
for science curiosity and the inside
that signs does not provide final
answers I mean some scientists I think
are not quite as down fall as they ought
to be you know my friend fossil record
once said it's not science that is
dangerous it's ignorance
after the Second World War the Yama's
had been isolated for quite some time so
two doctors here in Linda in this
medieval town which is behind me they
decided they wanted to invite some Nobel
laureates in physiology or medicine to
come here and to tell them what had
happened during the wall this was our
Father dr. Franz Culhane this was
Professor for parada and this is count
lena bena taught my father was in cancer
research until nineteen thirty-five at
the University of Munich in 1935 his
shift of as a dude align retired his
successor was a staunch Nazi and my
father who was had been a staunch
anti-nazi of course refused to become a
member of the party and upon which he
was thrown out of the University of
Munich dr. Hine moved his family to
lindau where he was able to set up in
private practice and after the war he
became active in local politics our
father was a member of the City Council
in 1948-49 and persuaded the city to
accept such a scientific meeting which
by that time the idea had escalated to
invite Nobel laureates the best of the
best it took him a little while to
persuade the City Council but the Lord
Mayor geheime hot doctor fish supported
him there was a tremendous atmosphere of
wanting to break out of the isolation
that had been experienced and wanting to
move forward and wanting to make
connections again he's a shaft VAR full
vida fighters I'm house so common under
a mansion and dimensional sunderland on
telling to Ireland as well Thomas
on one side when hutter anglich newer
optimus was kind of a see mrs. McCracken
who are charging more for that they
approached the count Leon up an adult
from the swedish royal family and
together they actually managed to get
some money to get the town to to help
them and in 1951 that was the first
meeting having been born in 1945 I was
barely not even quite six years old so
of course I had to come along as the
little girl I have some very very
special memories of these times as i
grew up with this and then this
brilliant idea killer we should invite
young people students young researchers
and even though the idea may not have
emanated with countless panels he was
the one who actually made it happen he
organized the 1954 meeting which was the
first one why really handles of students
were present the students met many
scientists who fled from Germany during
the war and it only returned because of
the lindau meetings indeed for some of
these scientists lindau became a place
for reconciliation between estranged
friends and former colleagues in some
cases it was possible and in some cases
as for example Einstein who never came
back to Germany and in his
correspondence berated Max böhm for
having returned and Max bone mentions in
one of his letters one of the positive
experiences was
the meeting in lindo max born came back
after the war and he's here in lindau
together with his old student than a
Heisenberg who stayed here and who to
guide to develop the German atomic bomb
and they are talking peacefully with
each other there was an atmosphere that
was very special here that allowed for
not only a scientific meeting but also
for human encounters for many years the
lindau meetings were German speaking and
most of those who came were from the
countries around the lake Germany
Austria and Switzerland it's amazing for
me even to tell you that they came here
first 49 years ago when I had just
finished my studies of chemistry in Graz
I was sponsored by some government
agency whose name i forgot i stayed in
Rome and I met for the first time some
of the great names I had only heard
about or read about in books and I
actually drank a glass of beer with me
shook hands with me and discussed the
science with me I never forget this
experience I was lucky in meeting some
very modest but very influential Nobel
laureates one was stalling her who was a
giant in the field of big molecules such
as nylon which was fairly new in those
days and Hans Krebs was a pioneer of
metabolism a field day later worked in
myself and these people simply set very
important things as asides they were not
pompous there were not arrogant they
were extremely modest
the meetings themselves were always held
on Linda but soon the grand closing
ceremony was staged count Leonard
bernadotte's private island of my now
and near his family home
the present chairman of the meetings
Wolfgang shura describes the next much
more significant development count
Leonard was a man fascinated to reach
out to the next generation and this is
how we met and how we forged a bond if
you wish when I met him he was already
quite an elderly gentleman and he was
always in a very very warm spirit and
the best thing I recall is to see the
radiance of his smile when we started
reaching out internationally when the
lower rates said we are very very happy
that this is now turning into an very
international meeting I think the
internationality of this meeting is one
of its greatest attributes and it grew
to enormous proportion in this you know
70 different countries it's really
unbelievable more than then
representative at the UN that are
sitting at one day in the General
Assembly the burner got family continues
to support the meetings through count
Leonard's daughter countess patina
countess patina is combining the best of
both of her parents the independence of
thought and the vision of her father and
the warmth of him and the perseverance
of her mother I certainly did not expect
to be the president of the Linda Nobel
meetings when I was a child but it was
from the beginning on very interesting
to meet the laureates we used to be
there whenever possible as children and
used to sit there during lunch pouring
water from one class to another through
small tubes and trying the experiments
you can do at a lunch table it was very
nice to grow into that meeting and to
see the dialogue between these young
people and the laureates and
it felt in the end quite natural that
this should happen that I should take
over the presidency from my mother I
know of no other event where so many
people give so freely of their time so
many people come together with so much
enthusiasm and not least so many donors
commercial organizations foundations put
so much money into it and expect nothing
whatsoever in return well what's quite
interesting is that when i came to
lindau first was which was about four or
five years ago I hadn't even known that
my father had been here at that time 45
years before that I think this is one of
the very few events that we've ever been
to together where you actually have
industry and science meet at this level
I think it probably wouldn't hurt to
underline what count Leonard's dream was
what do you how would you put it I think
his dream was to provide a place for an
intergenerational dialogue and without
regard to be it a nationalism and
nationality be it religion abia gender
he wanted to have one place where for
one week the world could meet the world
of science to listen to the lectures
even for me of this wonderful
discoveries and how they started simply
the beginning was always very simple
look at this shimomura that was diving
in the waters in the night and because
of the UV found this jellyfish that is
shining and now everybody in the
audience yesterday raised their hand to
say yes we do use gfp it started from
nothing from an observation of somebody
hearing people like John matha talk
about the future of the cosmos or David
gross talk about you know his space-time
quantized and this is a going to explain
the unification before I mean this is
just such a romantic wonderful stuff I
love it there's an amazing story of
Charlie towns who was developing the
maser when
was doing this to Nobel Prize winners
came in and told him it won't work you
know it won't work you're using up the
departmental money and he said basically
I was already an associate professor so
I knew they couldn't fire me and I sort
of went on and did it and of course we
have everything around as lasers mazes
and things of this nature so the advice
from that is don't listen to Nobel Prize
winners I think these people at this
conference are the movers and shakers of
the next few decades these are key
people all from all over the world and I
want them to understand that one of the
reasons that there's a conflict in a lot
of people's minds in the public's minds
with regard to science is that it's the
construct that human beings have
developed to determine what is true what
could be true and what might be true and
that is seen I think by many as
dangerous for people who want to control
society on the basis of dogma
I think there's no question that the
beauty of lindau with its wonderful
lakeside setting is an inspiration for
everybody and it is part of the reason
why people unwind here and enter into
the spirit of informality which i think
is so crucial you have outstanding
people and you have keen capable young
scientists and they will talk to each
other they bump into each other and they
will have tremendous pleasure from
talking about to the science and what it
is to be a scientist this experience has
been fantastic the meeting is unlike any
other I've been to and it's just because
of the interactions between the students
and the laureates there's no
intermediate the the purpose of the
meeting is to bring together students
from different countries and have them
interact with laureates and with each
other and that's exactly what what
happened I've been blown away by the
meeting
he likes me because brilliance you know
charming and enormous remodel I remember
here at lid now once a student told me
you know what's wrong with scientists
you're never sure of anything you ask
them to say yes well we think that and
he said that that's one of the
weaknesses of science and I told him
this is one of the god of science this
idea that you might be wrong you know
Einstein said it very well when he said
no experiment will ever prove that I'm
correct but one experiment at any time
can prove that I'm wrong and if
everybody had this feeling of the
possibility that they might be wrong it
would be the end of bigotry you know
fanaticism in those days science was
considered to be the only hope for the
future and I must admit I still see this
only home for almost 50 years later even
more so now than in those days and of
course to see the students coming out of
the discussions with Nobel laureates
with their eyes shining and I think it's
really like what Disney basically those
eyes that are like stars put and they
come out and it's it's a marvelous
experience so in this beautiful place
this beautiful setting and a lot of
people think that science is the
antithesis of those sorts of things of
this natural beauty and it's actually
the opposite science is the substance of
this beauty and I think that's fabulous
how many times in a lifetime of a
student does he have an opportunity to
me 20 30 40 50 Nobel laureates and just
to knock on the doors to bump into them
in the dining room to sit with them over
dinner and and to ask them whatever is
on their heart I mean this was my dream
as a kid and here all of a sudden you
can see that the lindo phone
nation can make this dream truth
you